you you mentioned that and you mentioned
the pressure on russia um
it's been reported uh that you've got
family links to russia that your wife
apparently has a stake in the indian i.t
consultancy firm
infosys
they operate in moscow they have an
office there they have a delivery office
there they've got a connection to the
alpha bank in moscow
are you giving advice to others that
you're you're not following in your own
home
that's not as i i'm an elected
politician and i'm here to talk to you
about what i'm responsible for my wife
is not
she is not but but equally if you you
know as a country we are asking
taxpayers to fund the uk's support for
ukraine we're asking people in the uk to
give their homes up to ukrainian
refugees
whereas it appears your family
potentially could be benefiting from
putin's regime
no i i really i don't think that's the
case and as i said the the operations of
all companies are up to them
we've put in place significant sanctions
and all the companies that we are
responsible for are following those as
they rightly showed sending a very
strong message uh to putin's aggression
do you know if infosys is
i have i have absolutely no idea because
i have nothing to do with that company